on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
alors je suis baptisée une rangée
je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre nouvel
épisode du petit émir la semaine
dernière nous avons découvert toute la
troupe à la cascade niagara pour un
pique nique et une séance de répétition
en pleine nature
cette semaine nous vous proposons de
partir à la découverte du métier de
musico thérapeute à travers le portrait
de mal aujourd'hui
mais elle a rendez vous au collège de la
montagne avec ses élèves en compagnie de
julien professeur de musique au collège
il participe comme chaque semaine à une
expérience de mixité avec une classe du
collège mais elle emmène ensuite tous
les jeunes en extérieur pour une séance
de batucada nous profitons de ce moment
pour interviewer julien le professeur de
musique
cette année on a intégré dans avec mes
élèves
l'ime de la montagne avec des enfants
handicapés
je l'intègre avec une 4e segpa la mixité
au collège de la montagne se passe bien
pour mes élèves ça
ce qui est bien c'est qu'il s'occupe
généralement ils arrivent à s'occuper
des enfants handicapés
je leur donne des rôles je leur demande
de les aider dans certain rythme et
quand ils n'arrivent pas à le faire et c
est je pense que les enfants handicapés
de l'ime sont heureux aussi de venir ici
sont toujours souriant il s'intègre
vraiment bien au collège
place ensuite à la séance de percussion
sur un air de samba
maël retourne un instant dans ma classe
puis repart pour l'ime de la montagne
par plus de seconde à perdre à l'ime
nous croisons désiré moniteurs et
éducateurs qui nous parle de maele ont
mal à constater que effectivement la
musicothérapie bon il ya psd ce public y
est beaucoup et permet aux autres de
s'exprimer de montrer et démontrer aussi
de savoir savoir faire savoir être et
c'est vrai que et permet à zoteux aussi
de grandir
on le voit sur l'autre gars et il faut
vraiment avoir pratiqué ça fait témoin
est d'avoir participé pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir comprendre un petit peu plus
c'est long mais c'est super intéressant
il faut continuer cette activité auprès
de ce public là bas elles vont ça fait
quelques mois je le connais a donc vu
moi je sais ce que moi je vois c'est que
c'est un professionnel un grand
professionnel on va même y trouve qu'il
y est proche du public un univers
l'écoutent
il est il est toujours en recherche un
petit peu de mesure de bien faire
ah et puis ce n'est un souci aussi les
discute il est bien sûr le groupe
nous terminons la journée dans une
interview de mails qui nous en dit un
peu plus sur son métier de musico
thérapeute la musique pour pour
atteindre des objectifs thérapeutiques
donc c'est le média musicale ce qu'on
appelle donc je vais pas forcément viser
l'aspect esthétique de la chose c'est à
dire que le but dans les séances de
musicothérapie c'est pas de faire du
beau particulièrement mais par contre ça
va être d'utiliser la musique pour pour
arriver à des objectifs que ce soit des
objectifs de communication ça soit des
objectifs de relaxation de développement
cognitif
donc tout ce qui est les processus du
cerveau les physiquement aussi ça va
permettre d'apporter vraiment quelque
chose sur la marche par exemple
abbas a à permettre d'avoir un certain
une rythmique a posé une certaine
rythmique donc donc développer toutes
ses facultés là ça permet de développer
et de soutenir et au final c'est la
musicothérapie et permet ça c'est aller
chercher les gens là où ils en sont peu
importe leur déficit peu importe peu
importe leur problématique pour essayer
de les soutenir et de la rapporter
quelque chose dans la vie que ça soit un
soutien que ça soit une possibilité de
communication que ça soit quelque chose
de tout bleu cathartique tout simplement
donc
donc voilà c'est vraiment le gros apport
de la musicothérapie est là la question
que je me pose de plus en plus c'est
qu'est ce que ne permet pas la
musicothérapie après il est bien évident
que car en place par un médecin c'est ça
c'est sûr elle remplace pas plein de
professionnels et par contre elle va
faire le lien entre ça va être un bon la
croisée des chemins en fait vraiment
c'est ça maintenant j'ai bon espoir que
que les gens réalisent petit à petit que
la différence n'est pas honteuse n'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas un mal d'être
porteurs de handicap
chacun a ses propres possibilités et
c'est un devoir de la société que
pouvoir leur permettre d'exploiter son
potentiel
et voilà c'est ainsi que s'achève cette
émission à très bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode du petit émir